good morning Hank it's Friday July 10th
you may remember in my last video I
offhandedly mentioned that Chewbacca
would make a great president and that
Han Solo should be his vice president
and chief translator it turns out that
idea had legs so I think there are
really only three main arguments against
Chewbacca becoming president to the
United States in 2012 argument one is
that we already have a suitable
president which you know fair enough but
he's not a Wookiee argument to which I
find somewhat more compelling is that
Chewbacca is not eligible to become the
president of the United States for a
bunch of reasons thank the United States
Constitution says that a president has
to be a natural-born citizen that he or
she has to be at least 35 years old and
must have been a resident of the United
States for at least 14 years so a
Chewbacca is not a natural-born citizen
in the United States because he lived a
long long time ago in a galaxy far far
away be he is currently deceased as
anyone who's read the 1999 Star Wars
novel vector prime already knows and see
he is a fictional character Hank I'm not
gonna lie to you being a deceased
non-human non-american fictional
character does make it hard for you to
become president of the United States
but to the people who would say that
it's impossible let me remind you that
our Constitution can be amended so shut
up and let the wookie win argument 3 is
that Chewbacca might not be a good
president due to his poor communication
skills and kind of general bellicosity
which is ridiculous public servants need
to be more like Chewbacca loyal
self-sacrificing Yoda saving heroes so
Hank after the last video more than 100
nerdfighters commented that they wanted
to see a Chewie for president 2012
t-shirt we have designed such a t-shirt
and you can buy it at dftba.com link
over in the sidebar but nerdfighters
because we just designed the t-shirt
today it's not gonna get to you for like
three weeks so don't get mad at us so
yeah if you want the t-shirt that's
great go get it but don't get mad if it
doesn't come for a few weeks
PS just after I finish making this video
Hank sent me the most awesome Chewbacca
for president song I've ever heard in my
life we're gonna make it a free download
that goes with the t-shirt but here's a
little snippet of it while you look at
the beauty of the shirt Hank designed
Lynas pockets you know what's gonna
happen LLL rip their arms out of their
sockets hey thanks for bringing musical
life to my stupid ideas you'll see me on
Sunday the shirt won't ship for three
weeks the shirt won't it's so close to
cursing like I am right on the edge of
cursing